hi Matt Welch here co author of the  Declaration of Independence how  libertarian politics can fix what's  wrong with America we're here on ask a  libertarian day and we had a lot of  queries directed at the jacket and so  today I thought we'd ask a few of them  directly the first question comes  through carrot Diller from facebook does  your jacket give you libertarian  superpowers yes second question from 24  head calm who if I'm not mistaken is our  good old friend lone wacko verse on  Twitter asked has the Elvis estate  contacted you about misappropriation of  likeness no okay and the final question  comes from monica shelton i believe on  facebook where does nick's leather  jacket spend its summers in the closet  not that there's anything wrong thank  you very much this has been that wells  for asked a libertarian day  you